all right new video final frontier okay
let's let's try this French again it
worked out nicely in the in the last
game okay maybe he's going for this
wacky gambit line with before I always
play this kind of stuff to avoid it not
because it's so great just because I
don't know it don't know I'd really am
NOT a regular French player okay this is
some mm-hmm surprising okay at least you
want to go for a gambit now what I'm
wondering is can i play move like g5
here to undermine d5 g5g find pressurize
this pawn immediately okay oops I can
just take this okay very weird no idea
what is doing here
so yeah the c-4 was to get in the ship
to see five
yeah basically I'm just ajust a piece up
of course it's some blitz it's tricky
and so on but it's just a piece ok let's
try to get some okay my rope gun is
doing quite some good things here Queen
h4 this is winning I can just I can just
check here of course so this is much
simpler it takes vintage form should be
should be winning and no g2 should win
outright so Lucas the tech then I'm
threatening look h3 winning the Queen
you have no idea what night x g5 was
maybe he did some Mouse slip earlier it
was just annoyed at himself or something
the night x g5 wasn't exactly easy to
review it yeah okay take the Queen
should take you five now attacking your
things on taking the night
yeah okay Jade the only thing rook h8
Bishop f-ed Bishop b4 could be a bit a
bit annoying so what should I do
a king would be good on d7 just under
seven yeah maybe just think this happen
rook h7 a cocoon g8 and take on d3 and
push up to back to ya he covers this
maybe just um anyway or I could also
play this move here take your five I
mean I'm just a queen um okay but don't
think for a while at least don't want to
allow any counter play here still I can
I can I can just go here
yeah just to take the pawn weakness or
something something must fall here check
check rah rah rah on the board or caused
ornament requested take back requested
you nope no comment abort requirement
request to take back frosted offered
it's really amazing him you've got so
many idiot such enjoyment requested
table and roster abort or cost enjoyment
requested draw offered take back
requested well you might think it's a
game played by people actually enjoyment
a questo actually have a break abort
requested take back requested abort
requested draw offered enjoyment
requested take back requested maybe I
should really his switch off those
sounds take back roasted offered abort
requested check abort request
adjournment requested take back rojas
offered
okay made next move couple of more draw
office to come or take back stuff
waiting for some text messages here to
arrive no it's not the kind of person
who talks with you it just presses some
buttons to annoy you and now I think you
let the clock run down
yeah what can you say okay well he lets
the clock run down let me enter the the
mating move Queen have to mate yeah
basically he just gave away though this
piece here for nothing and then just
just lost but he managed i think around
50 draw office and adjournment office
which is not too bad in a 45-minute game
all right five seconds white forfeits on
time yeah okay well thanks for watching
anyway and it was less just content and
more of a study of of human well and no
comment here well thanks for watching
anyway